З поверненням до квантових обчислень на практиці. Цей епізод зосередиться на першому і часто найбільш
складному кроці у визначенні квантової програми. Відображення загальної задачі на circuit, який може виконуватися на квантовому
комп'ютері. Цей крок описує, як користувач, починаючи з певної обчислювальної
задачі, може перетворити її так, щоб квантовий комп'ютер міг її зрозуміти.
У попередніх уроках цієї серії, уроках два і три, ми обговорювали, що етап відображення є першим кроком із
чотирьох у фреймворку Qiskit patterns. З цих уроків ти, можливо, пам'ятаєш, що наша мета полягала в тому, щоб перетворити
або переписати обчислювальну задачу у вигляді функції вартості або очікуваного значення,
яке ми можемо обчислити за допомогою квантового комп'ютера.
У третьому уроці ми розглянули один конкретний приклад із задачею max cut —
задачею, яка є обчислювально складною і широко використовується в комбінаторній оптимізації.
У тому прикладі ми пройшли кілька кроків, щоб перетворити початковий граф на задачу, рідну для квантового обчислення. Ми
перетворили задачу пошуку максимальної кількості розрізів у графі у функцію вартості, потім переписали цю функцію вартості
у вигляді гамільтоніана та підготували пробний квантовий стан, основний стан якого
відповідає max cut. Нарешті, ми побудували квантовий circuit, що представляє пробний квантовий стан,
який нас цікавить, і додали конкретні gate, щоб дозволити стану еволюціонувати з часом. Ця послідовність кроків — це те, що ми
називаємо відображенням. І на загальному рівні ця процедура є загальною для багатьох інших застосувань, таких як квантова хімія
та квантове моделювання. Отже, не варто уникати того факту, що відображення може бути складним. Не існує
універсальної стратегії для кожної окремої задачі, тому це може бути лякаючим. Сьогодні я виділю
кілька репрезентативних прикладів різних задач і опишу, як вони були відображені в кожному випадку. Я швидко
нагадаю, що ми дізналися про задачі на графах, такі як ті, що використовуються в Max Cut, і присвячу решту лекції
тому, як відображати задачі, що з'являються в природі, такі як задачі молекулярної структури в біології, електронної
структури в хімії та моделювання квантових теорій поля у фізиці високих енергій.
Але перш ніж ми присвятимо більшу частину цього епізоду розгляду прикладів задач із літератури, я хочу дати тобі
загальний огляд основних речей, яких ми хочемо досягти та враховувати при відображенні задачі. Є
кілька речей, які слід врахувати для будь-якого типу обчислювальної задачі, яку потрібно буде перетворити в квантовий circuit.
По-перше, тобі, можливо, доведеться спростити задачу, щоб зробити її здійсненною. Це є загальноприйнятою практикою для більшості наукових
дисциплін. Це не є унікальним для квантових обчислень. Якщо ти коли-небудь чув вислів «припусти,
що корова сферична», він натякає на той факт, що часто важко описати систему точно такою, якою вона є насправді. Але
натомість ми можемо робити розумні спрощення, які все одно можуть привести до корисних рішень.
Деякі приклади того, як ми можемо це зробити в квантових обчисленнях, — це обмежити розмір або глибину circuit шляхом вибору
апаратно ефективного ансатцу або скорочення складних часових еволюцій, або нехтування
членами гамільтоніана, що незначно впливають на кінцеву енергію квантового стану.
Наступне, на що я хочу звернути увагу, — це те, що тобі доведеться подумати про те, як записати задачу таким чином, щоб квантовий комп'ютер міг її зрозуміти.
Часто це передбачає відповідь на три питання. Перше: що представлятимуть наші qubit
у цій моделі? Друге: чи є наша задача неперервною? Оскільки квантові комп'ютери є цифровими, тобі потрібно буде
знайти спосіб дискретизувати задачу. І третє, нарешті: чи збігається топологія задачі з топологією
апаратного забезпечення? Якщо так, чудово. Але якщо ні, нам, можливо, доведеться застосувати деякі прийоми, щоб це спрацювало. Отже, давай розглянемо
це перше питання. Те, що я вважаю серцем усіх труднощів із розумінням відображення, особливо як
нового концепту. Що може представляти qubit?
Qubit можна використовувати для представлення багатьох речей. Перше і найпростіше, на мою думку, — це вузол на графі. Графи
використовуються для відображення зв'язності і в багатьох різних типах математичних задач. І вузли є фундаментальним елементом, що представляє точку
або сутність у мережі. Залежно від того, що представляє вся мережа, це може бути місто, людина або
феромагнетик у решітці. Qubit також можна використовувати для представлення бозонів і ферміонів. Хоча я застережу тут,
що один окремий qubit не дорівнює рівно одному бозону або одному ферміону. Це трохи
складніше, і я незабаром поясню це детальніше, але загалом ланцюжок спінів, що підпорядковується певній статистиці, —
це те, що можна легко перенести на архітектуру qubit.
Тепер ми переходимо до прикладів, що є трохи складнішими. Для цих моделей вже не має сенсу
говорити про окремий qubit.
Натомість нам потрібні їх групи, щоб скласти щось фізичне. Наприклад,
група qubit, представлена тут на важкій шестикутній топології, може бути використана для представлення геометричних розташувань амінокислот
або полімерних ланцюгів. Інший приклад — моделювання розсіювання адронів
у моделях фізики високих енергій, яке можна виконати, моделюючи часову еволюцію хвильового пакета адронів. У цьому випадку
регістр qubit можна використовувати для кодування різних станів квантового поля. Вакуумний стан цього поля або
хвильовий пакет, що поширюється поверх цього вакууму.
Тепер я також хочу зазначити, що відображення задачі на квантовий комп'ютер має чіткі кроки: перший — відображення
станів на qubit і circuit, і другий — відображення функції вартості або очікуваного значення
квантових спостережуваних і операторів. Ми побачимо, як вони обробляються в конкретних прикладах. Але
наразі ми говорили достатньо абстрактно про виклик, що стоїть перед нами.
Давай тепер детально розглянемо ці приклади.
Почнімо з першого прикладу. На мою думку, одна з найпростіших задач відображення — та, яку ми вже
досить детально розглядали, — приклад max cut. У тій задачі відображення було досить простим для нас, тому що один qubit
WEBVTT
дорівнював одному вузлу нашого графа. Використання вузлів на графі є дуже інтуїтивним, і це
зручно, тому що відповідає багатьом застосуванням. Часто, коли хочеш змоделювати щось, що відповідає
серії вузлів, з'єднаних разом, якщо угруповання є бінарними, як нуль або один, або включені та не включені в
множину, ти можеш просто та природно відобразити ці вузли в біти або qubit.
У цьому прикладі, і навіть у тому, що ми масштабували до 100 qubit у 3-му епізоді, зв'язність графа
вже відповідала топології нашого надпровідного апаратного забезпечення. Тому нам не потрібно було турбуватися й про це. Але так буває не завжди.
І якщо у тебе є складніший або більш зв'язний граф, ніж ті приклади, які ми розглядали досі, тобі доведеться
реалізовувати swap gate. Але це насправді обробляється на другому кроці Qiskit patterns, який стосується
transpiler. Інша частина задачі max cut, яка робить її такою зручною, полягає в тому, що ми
вже знаємо, як виразити функцію вартості у вигляді гамільтоніана, використовуючи QUBO-формулювання.
Нагадаю, що в квантових обчисленнях та варіаційних квантових алгоритмах гамільтоніан функції вартості — це функція,
яка кодує оптимальне розв'язання задачі в основному стані гамільтоніана.
Для побудови гамільтоніана вартості ми змогли використати клас sparse poly op у Qiskit для задання
зв'язності нашого графа, і етап відображення до квантових операторів виконано. А квантовий circuit був
просто ансатцом QAOA. Якщо це тобі нічого не нагадує, будь ласка, поверніться та перегляньте епізод 3, де ми розбираємо
це набагато детальніше. А тепер давай трохи підвищимо складність. Далі ми розглянемо
приклад, змодельований у статті «Ресурсно ефективний квантовий алгоритм для згортання білків», написаній
IBM у співпраці з Університетом Нового Південного Уельсу. Трохи біохімічних знань. Білки —
це макромолекули, що складаються з довгих ланцюгів амінокислот. Ці довгі ланцюги згортаються
у складні структури, що виконують широкий спектр біологічних функцій.
Визначення структури білка у тривимірному просторі та розуміння зв'язків між
структурою і функцією є одними з найскладніших задач у сучасній біохімії.
Білки згортаються в корисні структури завдяки взаємодіям між самими амінокислотами.
По мірі того, як структура скручується і згортається, амінокислоти, що знаходяться далеко одна від одної в ланцюжку, можуть опинитися поруч
і можуть сильно взаємодіяти. Нам потрібно отримати гамільтоніан, що описує всі ці взаємодії між амінокислотами,
якщо ми хочемо передбачити, яка кінцева структура мінімізує енергію. Тут ми зосередимося на ланцюгах амінокислот і
на тому, як їх можна змоделювати на квантовому комп'ютері, а потім як ми можемо отримати відстані між амінокислотами для
обчислення енергій взаємодії.
З цим ми фактично зберемо всі необхідні внески до гамільтоніана для того, щоб змоделювати
його на квантовому комп'ютері. У реальних білках амінокислоти можуть займати безперервне різноманіття можливих положень.
Однак ми будемо використовувати спрощення і обмежимо їх моделлю решітки, де кожна амінокислота
займає точку на сітці. Тут автори використовували тетраедричну решітку.
Коротка примітка: тут ми кодуємо напрямок ребер, а не самі вузли, як у задачі max cut.
Кожен qubit представляє можливий однокроковий шлях уздовж тетраедричної сітки. Зауваж, що суміжні вузли були
позначені на цій діаграмі як A або B через їхні різні орієнтації в решітці.
Ланцюжок білка представлений як серія поворотів або напрямків на цій
решітці. Кожен поворот між амінокислотами може бути в одному з чотирьох напрямків,
що відповідають ребрам тетраедра.
Ці чотири можливих повороти кодуються чотирма qubit.
Це звучить трохи хитромудро. Тож давай розглянемо цей приклад трохи детальніше.
Розмістимо нашу першу амінокислоту в цій точці тетраедричної решітки. Напрямок до першої
амінокислоти до другої є довільним, оскільки систему завжди можна просто повернути так, щоб це ребро вказувало
в будь-якому бажаному напрямку. Тож розмістимо нашу другу амінокислоту тут. Це не так
легко побачити, але шлях від другої до третьої також є довільним. Усі три варіанти призведуть до
того, що два ребра матимуть кут приблизно 109,5°
між ними. Вибір цього другого ребра просто визначає орієнтацію нашого білка в просторі. Тому без втрати
загальності ми можемо обрати перші повороти просто як 0 0 1 і 0 0 1
0. З цими спрощеннями конфігурація ланцюжка амінокислот просто задається цим виразом.
До цього моменту ми відобразили ребра тетраедра на qubit і наш квантовий circuit буде ансатцом. Тепер нам потрібно
врахувати, як закодувати енергію задачі у гамільтоніан так, щоб його основний стан давав нам оптимальний
патерн згортання. Тепер для будь-якої заданої конфігурації буде пов'язана енергія, обумовлена
взаємодіями між самими амінокислотами. Ці взаємодії є найсильнішими, коли дві амінокислоти знаходяться
близько одна до одної. Очевидно, амінокислоти, які є суміжними в основному ланцюжку, завжди будуть взаємодіяти одна з одною.
Але оскільки білок може скручуватися і згортатися, інші пари амінокислот
також можуть взаємодіяти. Амінокислоти 10 і 20, наприклад, можуть опинитися на
суміжних вузлах після того, як білок згорнувся. Амінокислоти, які виявляються поблизу одна одної, мають сильніші
взаємодії і рухають процес згортання, але вони не обов'язково мають індекси, що є близькими одне до одного.
Тому нам потрібна формула для опису відстані D між амінокислотами I та
J, використовуючи інформацію, закодовану на конфігураційних qubit. Таким чином ми можемо
використовувати їхню відстань розділення, щоб визначити, наскільки сильно вони взаємодіють. Це трохи складно,
але потерпи, бо це хитрий прийом. Спочатку давай введемо функцію f нижній індекс a від i, яка вказує, чи
WEBVTT
використовується ребро a для повороту в амінокислоті i. Тут a може набувати будь-якого
з чотирьох можливих напрямків з огляду на кодування конфігурації вище. Ми можемо записати ці функції, а потім
можемо визначити різницю в кількості поворотів із міткою a на решітках A і B від
індексу I до індексу J як delta N. Навіщо це робити? Виявляється, що
тетраедрична решітка має дуже корисну властивість. Зосередимося на цій амінокислоті тут. Не важливо, яка це,
але назвемо її амінокислотою E. Ми хочемо знати, наскільки далеко буде амінокислота j. І все, що у нас є,
— це ребра, вздовж яких рухається основний ланцюжок. Починаючи з I, зауваж, що крок
від центру вздовж певного типу ребра, назвемо його a, від цього вузла решітки a
точно протилежний і скасовується кроком вздовж ребра a від
вузлів b. Тому кілька кроків вздовж ребра A від будь-якого вузла решітки A переміщують
основний ланцюжок від амінокислоти E, а кроки вздовж типу ребра A від вузлів B
повертають тебе назад. Тому відстань між двома амінокислотами I і J вздовж типу ребра,
який ми позначимо A, залежить від різниці між кроками, зробленими вздовж ребер A
від вузлів A і вузлів B. Оскільки A і B обов'язково чергуються в
основному ланцюжку білка, це відображається членом мінус1 до степеня K. І цей аргумент застосовується до інших типів ребер
також. Тому відстань між амінокислотами в кроках тетраедричної решітки може бути обчислена в кінцевому підсумку за допомогою цього
виразу. Але як отримати гамільтоніан із цього довгого рівняння для загальної відстані між амінокислотами?
Насправді існує взаємно однозначна відповідність між цими відстанями в кроках тетраедричної решітки та евклідовою
відстанню. І ти можеш бачити, що я вже обчислив деякі з виразів для тебе.
Ці відстані можна використовувати для обчислення енергії твоєї конфігурації.
Залежно від твоєї мети, ти можеш задати порогову відстань, нижче якої вважаєш пару такою, що взаємодіє,
або можеш зробити щось складніше. Можливо, це неочевидно, але ми насправді вже закінчили з етапом відображення,
зробивши це. Стани qubit вказують поворот, а сукупність поворотів визначає
відстань між будь-якою парою амінокислот. Пари різних видів амінокислот
мають різні взаємодії, деякі притягальні, деякі відштовхувальні. Якщо ти використовуєш конфігурацію та відстань для того, щоб
просто визначити, чи ввімкнені або вимкнені відомі взаємодії амінокислот,
їх величини добре відомі. Не мені, але ти можеш знайти їх у таблиці, наприклад такій. Отже, підсумовуючи,
у цьому прикладі qubit використовуються для позначення розташувань у решітці, які разом утворюють ланцюжок амінокислот.
І моделюючи те, як вони згинаються і складаються, ми сподіваємось знайти кращі результати в медичних дослідженнях. Тепер,
ми пропустили обчислення кількох членів цього гамільтоніана, оскільки вони були дуже специфічними для цієї задачі. Хоча визначення
напрямків на решітці може бути застосоване більш загально.
Тепер, маючи загальний гамільтоніан, ти завжди захочеш перекласти його в Паулі-оператори, які є
рідними для квантового комп'ютера. Саме це ми обговоримо далі.
Продовжимо. Тепер давай розглянемо, як перетворити систему субатомних частинок на Паулі-оператори. Субатомні
частинки поділяються на дві категорії: бозони та ферміони. Бозони,
як-от фотони або хіггс-бозон, підпорядковуються певному набору статистичних правил, а ферміони, як-от електрони або нейтрино, підпорядковуються іншому.
Ключова відмінність між ними полягає в тому, що бозони можуть займати однаковий стан. Немає обмежень на те, скільки
бозонів може перебувати в основному стані або в будь-якому іншому збудженому стані. Ферміони ж, навпаки, є «егоїстичними». Вони вимагають, щоб
кожна окрема частинка мала власний квантовий стан. Бозони також мають цілочисельний спін, тоді як ферміони мають напівцілий
спін, як електрон зі спіном 1/2 або більш екзотичні частинки зі спіном три-половини. Для
опису системи частинок нам потрібен опис їхньої енергії. Зосередимося на ферміонах. Ми можемо почати з
гамільтоніана, записаного через те, що ми називаємо операторами C. Це, по суті, математичні об'єкти, що
відповідають створенню або знищенню ферміона зі стану в системі.
Їх часто записують як fi дагер і fi в нотації, яку ми називаємо вторинним
квантуванням. Тепер fi дагер — це оператор, що створює ферміон у стані i. Fi —
це оператор, що знищує ферміон у стані i. Але пам'ятай, квантові комп'ютери зазвичай працюють у базисі qubit
зі специфічними правилами для представлення ферміонних систем. Вони не працюють за своєю природою в мові
ферміонних операторів. Щоб подолати цей розрив, нам потрібно відобразити нотацію вторинного квантування на Паулі-оператори, які
природно відповідають квантовим gate.
Існує кілька таких перетворень для ферміонів. Поширеним вибором є перетворення Йордана-Вігнера.
Відображення Браві-Кітаєва та парне відображення є більш пізніми для мажоранних кодувань.
Бозонні операції, з іншого боку, можна перетворити за допомогою перетворення Гольштейна-Примакова або шляхом прямого
відображення станів Фока на підбазис доступних бозонних мод.
Для бозонів існують й інші варіанти. Інші кодування також активно досліджуються. Але зараз ми
зосередимося лише на перетворенні Йордана-Вігнера.
То чому б просто не призначити один qubit для представлення кожного електрона? Ну, ми не можемо.
Qubit є розрізнюваними, а електрони — ні. Наприклад, ми легко можемо позначити та ідентифікувати окремі qubit на
будь-якому пристрої, але нерозрізнюваність електронів означає, що ми взагалі не можемо їх позначати. Нам потрібно насправді позначати
натомість оператори відповідно до заповнених орбіталей, таких як 1s, 2s і 2p,
а не конкретних електронів. Таким чином, нам потрібно насправді позначати оператори відповідно до заповнених орбіталей, таких як 1s
2s і 2p, а не позначати конкретні електрони. Тому кожен qubit відіграє
WEBVTT
приблизно роль орбіталі в молекулі, яка або заповнена, або незаповнена.
Але те, як ми це робимо, насправді трохи складніше. Тому зараз ми вводимо так зване відображення Йордана-Вігнера, щоб відстежувати
антисиметрію та гарантувати, що правильна статистика загальної ферміонної системи дотримується. Відображення
Йордана-Вігнера є концептуально простим завдяки однозначній відповідності між орбіталями та qubit. Існують
інші відображення, що досягають подібної мети, включаючи парне відображення.
Обчислення парності стану вимагає розгляду кількох qubit. У парному відображенні та в деяких інших
інтерпретація відповідності одного qubit одній орбіталі не виконується.
Тепер давай разом розберемо досить простий приклад, щоб переконатись, що ми засвоїли це перетворення.
Скажімо, ми хочемо обчислити взаємодію одного qubit f дагер f. Починаємо з підстановки наших визначень для
операторів підвищення та пониження. Потім можемо згрупувати члени, виносячи за дужки одиничну матрицю i та 1/4.
Як бачимо, ми отримуємо члени, які виглядатимуть знайомими для тих, хто має справу з відношеннями комутації. Цей член тут у
дужках — не що інше, як i помножене на комутатор x нуль та y. І не
забудь про одиничний оператор, який ми виносили.
Пам'ятай, що це просто матриці Паулі. Тому комутатор є добре відомим. Комутатор x та y у
такому порядку простий. Це 2 i z. Слідкуй за знаками мінус і отримаєш це як свій кінцевий
результат. Зрештою ми успішно переписали ферміонний вираз
у термінах Паулі-операторів, які зможе зрозуміти наш квантовий комп'ютер.
Давай коротко обговоримо, як реалізувати відображення Йордана-Вігнера в Qiskit, тому що, хоча я вважаю
важливим розуміти, як це відображення та подібні перетворення працюють, і побачити хоча б один раз, як воно розбирається,
ти не захочеш робити всі ці обчислення вручну кожен раз.
Особливо для великих систем, зокрема, ми можемо скористатися функцією sparse poly op у Qiskit, щоб
легко створити пов'язані Паулі-операції з відображення. Неоптимальна
реалізація використовуватиме вкладені цикли і займає близько 20 рядків коду.
Я надішлю посилання на код для вас усіх для дослідження. Але на загальному рівні кроки такі.
Перше: використай функцію sparse poly ops from list для створення одиничного оператора,
що відповідає розміру параметричного простору для відображення. Друге: дотримуючись визначення операторів створення
та знищення, показаних раніше, використай функцію sparse polyops from list для визначення операцій Паулі x, y та z.
Це відобразить ферміонні оператори створення та знищення на спінові оператори qubit, кодуючи ферміонне
число заповнення в обчислювальний базис qubit, і третє — згенеруй бажаний
гамільтоніан у базисі Паулі, застосовуючи вищезазначені оператори до орбіталей інтересу. Зазвичай це відповідає
створенню одиничної матриці, що представляє ядро невзаємодіючих орбіталей, а потім застосуванню операторів створення
та знищення до активного простору з вагами, що відповідають особливостям задачі. Як
я вже зазначав, це лише загальний розбір. Проте код не надто складний, і ти тепер повинен
відчувати впевненість у його адаптації до інших задач, що тебе цікавлять.
Тепер, коли ми повністю розуміємо схему відображення Йордана-Вігнера, давай подивимося на неї в дії в більш складному налаштуванні. Ти
можеш пам'ятати цю статтю з попереднього епізоду про адронну динаміку. Я не збираюся знову детально розглядати статтю, але будь ласка, перегляньте
попередній епізод, якщо пропустили і цікавитесь. У цьому прикладі відображення Йордана-Вігнера використовується для
виразу гамільтоніана вузлів решітки з L вузлами для моделі Швінгера за відсутності електричного поля. Тут
набагато складніше конкретно вказати, що один qubit представляє в цій моделі, оскільки лише
сукупність qubit разом складає щось фізичне. У цьому контексті — хвильовий пакет. Натомість, ти можеш грубо
уявляти qubit як дискретизовані ділянки простору, де тут L — це об'єм решітки, в якому кожен елемент або
одинична комірка містить два qubit. Ферміонні оператори, які ми бачили на попередньому слайді, описують амплітуду
хвильової функції в конкретному вузлі.
Тому наш гамільтоніан містить ці ферміонні оператори підвищення та пониження. Але щоб реалізувати такий
гамільтоніан на квантовому комп'ютері, нам потрібно виразити його через спінові оператори, а не ферміонні оператори.
Тому ми використовуємо перетворення Йордана-Вігнера. Після застосування перетворення Йордана-Вігнера наш новий
гамільтоніан набуває вигляду цього рівняння внизу слайда, де сигма плюс — це Паулі-оператор X + I Y, а сигма
мінус — це X - IY. Маючи гамільтоніан у такому форматі,
найскладніша частина етапу відображення завершена, і його тепер можна легко записати в circuit через Паулі-оператори.
Підсумовуючи, ми обговорили чотири приклади того, як конкретні техніки відображення застосовувалися нещодавно в
квантових обчисленнях. Починаючи з найпростішого і поступово доходячи до застосування перетворення Йордана-Вігнера до
адронної динаміки. Я розумію, що це дуже багато. Цей матеріал дуже технічний,
і якщо ти не стикався з ним раніше, він може дуже лякати. Гарна новина полягає в тому, що обіцяю: стає легше і
звичніше, чим більше часу ти витрачаєш на практику. І це справжня суть гри, ось чому я назвав всю
серію «Квантові обчислення на практиці».
Це не те, що будь-хто може просто підхопити і бігти з самого початку. Це вимагає певного навчання, певного
розкушування голови і, мабуть, якихось розчаровуючих моментів. Але я заохочую вас усіх залишатися з дискомфортом і
справді досліджувати питання, що виникають, поки ти продовжуєш, тому що це єдиний спосіб справді навчитися. Дякую за
перегляд. Це був 5-й епізод квантових обчислень на практиці. Наступного разу ми розглянемо, як моделювати
гамільтоніан з нуля. Побачимося незабаром.